Peter what makes a good story
embarrassment truth ask yourself and you
can do it alone in a room write down on
a piece of paper the ten most horribly
embarrassing things secrets in your life
you would never want anyone ever to know
now we all have them you write down ten
of you don't ever want to show this to
anybody you don't have to but those 10
embarrassing personal secrets will fuel
almost all the stories you're ever gonna
tell in your life because every story
you tell is going to come out of one of
those horrible embarrassments because
they are what's wounded you and they
start when you're little and it's
usually our parents who wound us
sometimes it's a dirty old uncle you
know it sometimes it's a neighbor but
it's usually our parents so if you can
understand what those wounds are you're
gonna be able to write 10 compelling
characters all having behaviors that are
compensations for that wound like I said
mine one of mine was my mommy didn't
love me but it came out in body
dysmorphia yeah that won't be the case
for you the one wound I'm unlovable look
how it worked for Don Draper he became
mr. handsome he everything he did was
subducting yes so that's a difference
because everyone's different in how they
react to the core wound so this is the
most potent way to tell a great story
and it's about character you know Blake
Snyder wrote a great book called saving
the cat but he didn't talk much about
character and so this lecture I gave
yesterday which was killing the cat is
sort of like what else you need to know
about story if you want to write a
compelling story today character is
something that seems like a black box
for a lot of writers so I'm suggesting
what's more interesting about your life
than what happened to you your secrets
if you can't get interested in your own
secrets you're gonna write a boring care
well he's got to do this or you see
sometimes teachers go here's a list of
things write down a list of character
attributes so they like t they like I
don't know diapers
it seems so arbitrary right who cares
think about your own wound and what you
like what you avoided and what you still
avoid and I guarantee you geez can i
really say that i don't want to reveal
that about myself well you're gonna have
a boring story if you don't and even
writers that are very successful who
tell me Oh Peter I never do any of that
crap you know I'm completely unanalyzed
and I don't need analysis one page of
their script reveals all of that damage
whether they want it to or not it's
right there it's what they write about
you